on the public squares of hung Joo
dancing is a daily ritual good fun and
Better Health are the normal motivations
but dance as a medal-winning sport does
have a history here now when the Asian
Games was last in China in 2010 Dance
Sport made its first and up to now only
appearance medals were won in events
like The Jive the Tango the sber the fox
trots well dance boort is now back but
in hung Joo it will look look rather
different Ray King is making its Asian
Games debut and next year it will be at
the Olympics for the first time an art
form that began on the streets and in
the clubs of New York in the 1970s
started its journey into competitions a
couple of decades later it's hard
because a lot of people like no let's
just be keep it underground let's keep
it like that but underground will be
always there like you can always come
back and do it for fun fun and um but I
think it's time for for Breakin to go to
another level at the Asian Games and
Olympics so-called B boys and be girls
go face to face in Solo contests with
judges deciding the
winners while Olympic president Thomas
back isn't considered a medal Contender
breakings inclusion in the Paris 2024
games is an important move into the
mainstream break getting a chance to go
to something like the Olympics is huge I
think the Olympics are a great
opportunity for us to reach the global
scale of appreciation on that level of
an of an
event athletes at the Asian games are
within sight of that Global platform the
winners will automatically qualify for
the
Olympics it's my work for me because now
I'm a aate I love breaking because uh
when I dance I really happy it can
help me to translate my uh emotion like
when I happy I
dance the same principles apply within
hung joo's Street dancing culture which
will happily continue with or without
Olympic recognition Andy Richardson
alzer hung
Joo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer